so like you talked before about you know
the pressure of performing in japan
because they expect perfection and we've
talked before
on this podcast by like idol culture in
japan and how
they kind of expect perfection not only
like on the stage but
off the stage as well awesome yeah you
really get put on a pedestal here
here it seems like what's it like in
your position do you feel like you
you have the pressure to be like perfect
in every aspect of your life
or do you just not give a [ __ ] um
well during for example like the
concerts themselves are completely
different like i said
um japanese audiences tend to uh sort of
enjoy
the emcee talking sections a lot and so
they like to
hear about like your private life and
what you're doing and
like they like to hear you talk but then
they uh for example the overseas
audience
they just want to like have to do the
music
play the anime opening exactly so you
know i
end up not talking much on stage when i
go overseas but um
yeah i think in the japanese industry
though they they have like
they have exactly image of what kind of
concert they want to do and then you do
that exact kind of concert
and then also the fans have like a very
they like to im
like make you a character right yeah
funny character sort of thing so
um it was it was kind of interesting
though like
i became a nano character in the
beginning and um
i tried to sort of live up to that
expectation but then i realized that you
know it's kind of impossible
oh yeah so little by little like i'm
becoming a lot more freedom
yeah right now i'm just you know me but
have you ever had any uncomfortable
situations arise from you know trying to
be more yourself and the
fans wanting this perfect image of you
um
well i did sort of think about like uh
is this what sort of character nano
would do or say or not
you know that kind of thing weird
because you are mad
what would the fans think that i would
do i should do that
what is like the main difference between
the character nano and like
you as just nana it was really
sort of um distinct because i didn't
show my face in the beginning
right so anything that sort of showed
like a personality
no on stage i did but i mean photos
i never showed my face in photos and
stuff and so anything that sort of
showed a characteristic of myself human
side of nano
so so so if i'm understanding this
quickly they created a character not
like did they make a law around it or
was it just how they perceived
the way you would act off camera
well it was kind of like my artist image
as well so
my director also wanted to go in a
direction where i was
no not too open i was more mysterious
yeah yeah
and who's nano you know is is are they
a boy or a girl japanese audiences love
that [ __ ] they
love like the mysterious because you can
then apply
you know based off the music yeah yeah i
think oh i think they're like this and
they must be like this yeah
but actually it did help me focus on my
music more yeah
because i didn't have to um think about
you know what i looked like
what you know my image was like i could
just focus on my music and not you know
focus on the other aspects of the visual
aspects
yeah because i feel like a lot of people
forget that in the music industry
sometimes
a lot of like image is just as important
as the music as well so being able to
focus on the music
i feel it's a big advantage because you
can that just means you can just
focus on what you're really passionate
about
yeah but it's always like you know they
always think that
you know people on like uh x factor
and american idol american idol because
they're too humanized
to us and that we see them way too
similar to ourselves
they don't almost they don't work very
well as pop stars because they're not
larger than life characters yeah so i
feel like in almost some aspects you'll
kind of have to like not tell everyone
about everything about yourself because
they're going to think like oh well
i know everything about now she's like a
normal i'm a video person but if you're
like man oh my god
mysterious person who's amazing at music
yeah
the facade is gone we are breaking the
fourth wall now
yeah like i i saw like it's very similar
to like um i read like this article on
uh how
the reason why daft punk uh hides their
faces now
yeah it's because like yeah it's exactly
the same thing it's like they just want
to like completely focus on the music
they want to like
basically cut off the connection between
the person making the music and the
actual music so
yeah now the two members of dark punk
they can do whatever the [ __ ] they want
in their personal life like no one can
say anything otherwise right so they
could they could be at their own concert
in the crowd and no one would actually
know but that was so convenient because
i could go anywhere and do anything
without people
realizing who i was right so i could you
know go to the convenience store in
pajamas and be like whoo-hoo
yeah would you do that when you had your
faces
[Laughter]
have you ever been noticed or like
recognized in japan absolutely no i
haven't
really wow what if you have but they
just didn't come to you
yeah japanese right yeah
from a distance on my wikipedia is it
does it say that no
no no no no convenience stores in my
pajamas
that in her pajamas at a family mart
was there tmz that does that now is
there like a japanese tmz
or i don't know it's just just seeing
like the uh
what's the youtubers like youtuber tmz
oh no i have seen that
really creepy they like follow like the
thought filter right something like that
something like that
like the 13 14 tick tock stars yeah some
questions it's like what do you
think it's mostly it's mostly in la
right yeah
because i i see some of those you know
tmd youtubers now and i
i get this image that just la youtubers
live on a different
planet yeah la just works differently
from the rest of the world i'm pretty
sure
but i spent so much time um you know not
having
an identity yeah so for like years and
years i spend doing music
just you know without an identity so now
that i
do have an identity and i'm more free
now sometimes i don't know who i am
sometimes i'm like you know lost at that
point but um
oh this is getting pretty deep no i i i
totally get it though it's like
you know it is a very uncomfortable
thing where you're like am i
the character that people think i am or
what is because
this is stressful because i i've i've
experienced like something similar doing
youtube where
i don't know if my personal because my
personality has shifted in like the 10
years i've done youtube but
have i shifted because i've done youtube
or have i
you know have i shifted because of my
own personal reasons i don't know
the way i try and like tell people at
least i think i tell myself this to like
this is right right
like like i i think i present like an
image of myself that is like me on my
best days
right it's you know because obviously
you know you get sad you you get get
those days you don't want to do anything
and you're literally
you're sure you're here yeah yeah yeah
not fun to be around obviously i'm not
going to show that but then it's like am
i lying by not showing that like i don't
know i hate exactly it's uncomfortable
because i i i feel like that when
there's a camera i feel like i have to
be in like the good mode the
entertaining mode where
sometimes you know you just don't feel
like being entertaining or talking
um i just gotta like take the smile pill
right
yeah it's it's tough like and i feel
like you know
i i can completely see why like you know
especially on the youtuber side right
like
why there's kind of been this like kind
of i've almost seen as like a growing
thing of
faceless youtubers just because i think
people are starting to realize
the kind of not risk per se but you know
the the demerits to like
showing your face and showing your self
honesty
it's way more pressure and i've noticed
that since because i i started off with
most people not knowing much about me
and then trash taste started
and now i'm on camera every week and
it's something that i just haven't been
used to at all
i just can't be bothered going through
all the effort of like hiding my
identity
but you know like i said earlier though
i think the japanese industry
the entertainment industry used to be
very sort of strict and they expected
you to sort of portray
an artist's image and yeah like idols
and
like it was a it would be a huge scandal
right if they were dating something yeah
but um thanks to youtube and like this
recent sort of generation
um you know a lot of musicians and uh
entertainers are starting to become
youtubers
i think that's a huge plus because
they're realizing that they can be
themselves more and still work and be
human yeah and be human and
people are actually looking for that now
yeah and so
this is a huge uh big sort of uh
you know plus for the entertainment
industry and i think it's a good change
for us
and i feel it's a chance for us to be
more of ourselves and to
really um put out you know our own
messages
into our work did you have any control
over your own like
artist image or was that all the
beginning um this is my first time
actually talking about this and i would
love to talk about it actually
okay exclusive let's go let's go no but
everything
in the beginning of my uh career because
i was completely amateur
like usually rock artists start
doing their stuff before their w like
they do small lives venues yeah
tours they have a fan base but for me
like day one that my fans uh
you know made a debut with me was my day
one as well right
and i didn't do lives before that i
didn't have media coverage anything out
there so
it was just nico nico and so um
i needed aid i needed direction
yeah and so um my director and
made sort of this image of who what kind
of artist i should be
and i tried to sort of um be
that right that i could so in the
beginning though
um everything was completely like you
know
um decided for you yes decided for me
and i didn't even know what i wanted yet
as a musician
yeah so i couldn't say you know hey i
want to do this i wanted
i just wanted to sing yeah right right
that's how it normally is artists just
kind of
a lot of things i notice about artists
is that they just want to focus on the
art and they have
no idea about how to market themselves
or branding
helped me to have the direction right
and to be told like you know
um everything other than the singing
part to do how to do this how to do that
they taught me about the entertainment
industry they taught me how to do lives
they taught me how to take hardest
photographs you know
everything god i wish i knew that yeah
right we just kind of had to like learn
on the job and take
an array of the most awkward photos that
have ever been taken
it was so sad because i didn't show my
face but i had to take artist
photographs i was always wearing a hood
right yeah so i was like standing in
front of the camera wearing a hood and
not showing my face
and i was like you know this could be
anyone else anyone else
yeah a mannequin and no one did notice
yeah
does it have to be me you know that kind
of thing even my promotion videos i
didn't show my face and so my neck was
always like this and by the end of the
video
i'd be like oh my god my neck
so you know that that happened behind
the cameras and there were a lot of
things that were difficult in the
beginning
right but now that i think about it it
was really funny
it was it was really funny and fun and
it helped me learn about a lot of things